[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new batman video for
the teaser that they just released for
the brand new project called batman
unburied that's coming next year
that's right there are so many batman
things happening next year between all
the movies and the new projects so we'll
break it down explain what's going on
with this if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we'll do a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which new
batman project you're most excited about
next year
so just starting with the big stuff
first number five if you didn't see the
news dc just announced a brand new
batman project for 2021 in addition
to the batman movie with robert
pattinson the new ben affleck stuff that
they're doing in justice league snyder
cut
the flash movie in the batman the long
halloween movie that they're also
releasing
next year that is a whole lot of batman
this
new batman project will be called batman
unburied and it's actually david goyer
coming back who wrote on the christian
bale dark knight trilogy of batman
movies
coming back to write and executive
produce it they're saying that it's
being done as one of dc's new premium
partnerships between warner brothers and
spotify so it'll be released on spotify
presumably some point during 2021 they
didn't say when exactly the early part
of the year or the end of the year
most of the batman projects the batman
movies that are coming out between
batman the long halloween and the robber
pattinson batman movie are coming out
towards the end of next year
he didn't completely give away what the
story is going to be but he did say that
they'll be using their unique advantages
to dig into the more nightmarish members
of batman's rogues gallery
so i'll explain which villains they're
probably talking about in a second
the series is supposed to explore the
darker aspects of bruce wayne's
psychology that might sound familiar for
those of you that have read some of the
more hardcore
classic batman stories so whereas the
batman movie with robert pattinson is
meant to be more of a noir detective
thriller take on the character
this new batman unburied project will be
more of a psychological horror batman
story
i feel like batman and horror go really
well together since he trades so much on
the tropes of horror stories for his
movies and pursuit of justice every
night
when they're talking about digging into
the more nightmarish batman villains
they're talking about people like mad
hatter
scarecrow man bat professor pig of
course the joker always makes those
lists you can't make a list about
horrific batman villains without talking
about the joker
do you want to tell it to me
[Music]
number four they're saying this batman
unburied project isn't a one-off either
it's meant to be the first of many new
premium narrative projects like this so
if you like this type of thing
they might be doing more special batman
stories and other major characters
eventually
the reason they're starting with new
batman stuff is because next year is the
year of batman between all the different
live-action movies and animated movies
that are coming out
cue all the batman memes how much batman
do you want
yes the other big batman movie that's
coming out next year in addition to the
robert pattinson batman movie
is the long halloween movie it's
actually going to be two parts but both
part one and part two will be released
during next year so you don't have to
wait too long to get that part two after
seeing the first half
the reason they're doing it in two parts
is just to give them the space they need
to tell a more comic book accurate
version of the long halloween because
it's a really big story
and even though the robert pattinson
batman movie is borrowing some aspects
of the long halloween story
matt reeves is doing an original story
so the plot will be very different the
characters will be very different as
you've seen from some of the trailer
footage
like a combination of seven from david
fincher and batman the long halloween
one of the reasons why they typically
don't do straight up rips of comic book
story plots for live action movies is
just because they like to give you
something that you haven't already
seen so the comics don't wind up being
huge spoilers for the endings of the
movies
most of the time and because they sign
these bigger directors like christopher
nolan or matt reeves
they usually want them to redefine the
way that everyone thinks about batman as
a character and the batman movies in
general
so cue all the footage of george clooney
batman then cut to the scene of
christopher nolan
meeting with warner brothers before
making the dark knight trilogy
you could just see them asking him
please make batman cool again
do whatever you want to with the
character within reason
i spoke to them a lot about what i was
trying to achieve with bruce wayne
when it comes to batman
i had no idea what i was looking for in
truth
because you you simply don't know how
the actor is then going to
put this very fanciful costume on and
make this guy
believable in that world all i could do
was really give them
ideas on the logic behind aspects of the
costume the idea that it's
meant to terrify and threaten criminals
in fact when christopher nolan said that
he signed on for the dark knight trilogy
he actually said that he told warner
brothers please while i'm doing this
re-envisioning this version of batman
don't start doing a bunch of other
versions of batman on any of the tv
shows
or any other places that's one of the
main reasons why you never saw
batman on tv during the smallville era
of tv shows when they were doing
superman stuff or during any of the
subsequent tv shows
they kind of did a version of batman on
the gotham tv show but not really it was
a really work around version of a batman
character
obviously that era has kind of changed
now because we have the batman hbo
series that's going to be a spin-off of
the batman movie with robert pattinson
so we don't really know how they're
going to invoke batman during that yet
but now in this new era of streaming big
budget dc
shows we're going to see a lot more big
movie level content coming in tv form
the justice league snyder cut is
probably the best example that because
it's a movie but they're kind of
releasing it like a tv show
number three just to be clear though the
batman unburied project isn't supposed
to be connected to matt reeves the
batman movie or any of those sequels and
it's not meant to be connected to the
justice league snyder cut the ben
affleck batman stuff
anything like that they're treating it a
little bit more like the joker movie
with joaquin phoenix the dc
black label stuff in that it's a much
more hardcore take on the character than
you've seen in the movie so far
and it's kind of in a separate universe
for the most part just treat it like
it's in its own continuity
so you won't have to watch every single
batman thing that's going on next year
just to understand what the story is of
this new project
but if things go well with it i think
they probably intend to do sequels with
the same cast coming back
the same way that they keep bringing
kevin conroy back as batman in new
animated movies all the time because he
was so great as batman and everyone
loves him so much
this was a clip of him talking about
finally getting to play live-action
batman during crisis on infinite earths
oh i never thought i'd get a chance to
do it on camera because i was getting
older and older and older i was sort of
aging out of batman you know
but luckily i aged into old bruce wayne
that was kind of them doing a version of
kingdom come batman because of that
harness
combined with some batman beyond easter
eggs thrown in the earth that his batman
was from
was earth 99 which is a reference to the
year batman beyond started airing in
1999.
i know about all the rumors of michael
keaton live action batman beyond movies
happening at some point
i'll do more videos about that if we get
any kind of confirmation because it
would be a dream come true to see
live action batman beyond number two you
may also remember a little while ago
marvel tried a similar project like this
with the wolverine character
no joke marvel did a wolverine solo
series in the last couple of years
it wasn't on spotify and i don't think
it got a lot of promotion
just because it was a different actor
playing the wolverine character
it was also happening while hugh jackman
was still wolverine
they hadn't quite released the logan
movie yet so they were still tail end
hugh jackman era wolverine and i think
that marvel and fox wanted most of the
attention
on that so the wolverine solo series
didn't get nearly as much attention as
it could have
the person playing wolverine during that
was actually richard armitage from the
hobbit movies it was called wolverine
the long
trail and it also featured gambit for
those of you that are still wondering if
they're ever going to make that gambit
movie
this is a little clip of what that
sounded like
what the hell were you doing at her
apartment who the hell is this guy i'm
an old friend
also if you've ever listened to the
classic superman radio dramas from a
long long time ago
imagine a batman horror story done like
that and
number one speaking of which there was
also a similar special new superman
project they announced a dc fandom
that's a little bit like this
but i think that's being done by a
completely different group of people
on a different platform but it's
basically them doing another superman
narrative
reimagining of the classic superman
radio dramas with new actors
either way it sounds really cool and i'm
happy that dc is finally spending some
more money taking some chances on
premium content like this especially
since
2020 has been such a crap year with
practically zero new content from dc and
marvel
it seems like every week they tell us
about something really cool that's
coming
next year i will do more videos for this
new batman unburied
project when they release a new trailer
next year and announce who the cast is
going to be and of course i'll be doing
regular videos for the batman movie in
all the batman movies coming out next
year
speaking of which they just released a
new trailer for the batman red hood
movie that's coming out later this year
that's right there is new batman stuff
coming later this year
i'll post that later tonight as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see that when i post it
but everyone click here to learn about
all the new batman justice league snyder
cut scenes that zack snyder is going to
be filming this month and click here for
that brand new
avengers 1 division trailer in marvel
easter eggs thank you so much for
watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
[Music]
tonight
you